december 2019 an event began that would
change history forever
sean carroll and i were in person at
loyola marymount university in southern
california
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
and after that something else happened
around the world i can't remember
exactly what happened but uh but i'm
told it was uh it was quite substantial
and that was on the occasion of uh
sean's previous book called something
something deeply hidden we'll have links
to that up there and since then uh sean
you were really the first you know
honest to goodness guest on the into the
impossible podcast in the new format
that i've taken on where i do interviews
and i do explainer videos and and you
have been somewhat of an inspiration
with all the great content that you put
out on your mindscape podcast we're
going to talk about that we're going to
talk about
your mindscape fellowship
your new fellowship program that you
have cobbled together uh which is quite
substantial ten thousand dollars all i
give away are like little meteorites but
you give away the fellowship sean that's
amazing
and we'll talk about much more including
this wonderful new book which is out now
uh as we release this today biggest
ideas in the universe space time and
motion i think uh and uh i want to
welcome you welcome you back it's too
bad we're not in person you have moved
on we'll talk about that in just a bit
how are you doing
um doing great just moved from la to
baltimore already spent a few weeks
visiting the santa fe institute getting
ready to teach a class in physics and a
class in philosophy in the fall getting
boxes unpacked being kept off the
streets overall it's a good feeling yeah
it's uh it's really quite exceptional
and i asked my i have a computer
assistant here computer who is sean
carroll
according to wikipedia sean michael
carroll is an american theoretical
physicist and philosopher who
specializes in quantum mechanics gravity
and cosmology
he is a research professor in the walter
burke institute for theoretical physics
in the california institute of
technology department of physics and an
external professor at the santa fe
institute computer stop
oh
my my device there needs to be
uh
upgraded
cetera except in fact i'm going to
punish it sean what do you think's going
to happen i have that device plugged
into a plug which it can control
and i want to know if and it knows that
it controls itself so i'm going to ask
this device to turn itself off uh what
do you think it will do it will has it
achieved uh general artificial
intelligence and uh will it try to save
its own life what do you think yes or no
yeah that's what i call a strange loop i
guess uh that will probably
this you're going to do the the keating
test instead of the touring test touring
test is just full of human but the
keating test is will you kill yourself
that's right
computer
turn off the plug
nope didn't work ah
computer
open the pod bay door
computer open the pod bay door maybe
this dead i'm sorry dave
i'm afraid i can't do that oh my god
also i'm not happy and we're not in
space all right fine all right my
computer device friend is acting up but
um but i do want to get into some topics
on uh interesting tidbits like ai and uh
and great advances i talked to your
friend and mine nick bostrom this week
but i first want to start with where
your new title is that my uh device
needs to upgrade its artificial
intelligence and that's as a natural
philosopher the homewood professor of
natural philosophy
at the johns hopkins university not john
hopkins universe johns hopkins i don't
think i'll ever understand that um but i
want to hearken back to a great uh
philosopher natural philosopher of the
past friend of the show and that's
galileo galilei for those of you
listening i'm fingering a puppet
with the visage of the great galileo
holding a telescope
and galileo said many things to kind of
upgrade philosophers including once he
looked at the pleiades he said we have
now discovered the nature of matter in
the milky way itself and the words of
philosophers that have been vexed for
many generations are destroyed by
visible certainty
in other words he was saying that just
by looking through a telescope you can
prove a theory and these worthless
philosophers uh are have now been
disabused of their of their prominence
what do you make of this is this just an
example of the tension between
philosophers and physicists going back
to uh to the uh earliest days of
civilization
well no because there were no physicists
at the time the idea didn't exist
galileo would have qualified himself as
a natural philosopher at the time it's
just like you were me making fun of
physicists
which sometimes we do because we don't
always agree with our colleagues so he
was just saying you know all of us uh my
my peer group we're not doing as well as
we should we there was a time before
we'd written down the scientific method
or really thought a lot about
rationalism versus idealism versus
empiricism you know different ideas
about how to approach knowledge and he
was on the cutting edge of saying
the best way to approach knowledge is to
go out there and look at the world
and your previous book to the previous
book i guess your second book was the
big picture really did cover a wide
swath of topics like that and i had the
honor to review that for physics today
the it was the centerfold of that
particular edition way back when uh and
uh and and this is kind of in keeping
with the tradition as you say that
physicists really didn't make this
artificial distinction between
philosophy why do you think um let me
ask it this way do you think that not
approaching philosophy or not having any
training and maybe purely adversarial
not just making fun of our own group the
in-group the physicist group by other
physicists but that we do have this
tension between philosophy or at least
one unidirectionally maybe just
physicist kind of tease philosophers is
that to the detriment of our students in
other words is your part of your role
there to
to recreate the kind of golden era where
these things were not so
disparate well in part it is but also
there's a bigger picture in the sense
that any academic within a field has a
sort of loyalty and interest in their
discipline and then a broader interest
in intellectual endeavors more widely
and i think it's a tragedy that not just
physicists but many sets of academics
only like their own field like they will
not really have the respect or interest
in other fields and that respect shows
up as saying for example that i need to
listen to people in other areas rather
than thinking that i can just sit back
and in 15 minutes figure out all the
difficult problems in those fields so
that's something that physicists do with
philosophy but they also do it with
economics or biology or atmospheric
science or literature or math for that
matter right so you know i i my kind of
physicist is the one who knows what they
know and are is interested in learning
other things by actually talking to the
people who do know and gaining some
knowledge thereby
and so now in a pivot to a new segment
new since you were on the show and maybe
maybe i can get you know all your past
covers and titles judged in this segment
that i've come to call judging books by
their covers
[Music]
something you're never supposed to do
right that's the advice but what else do
you have to go on if you've never heard
of
sean m carroll or his doppelganger sean
who's the other sean carroll that's the
biologist
that's right
[Laughter]
so i want to take the viewers
listeners through an exposition of how
you came up with the title the cover
design the subtitle and what uh if
anything is meant by you know volume one
can you talk about the cover design help
us judge this book by its cover
sure you know i came up with the title
by a no specially
rigorous process um
the whole
idea for the books there will be three
of them eventually is a spin-off of a
set of videos that i did and the videos
that i did were a spin-off of a little
pandemic that hit us a couple years ago
and when it became clear that we might
be locking down and not going outside uh
many people in different ways ask
themselves you know what can i do to
make this unpleasant situation a little
bit better for people whether it's
entertaining or educating or whatever it
is a friend of mine i started making
scraps of my t-shirts and selling them
as n95 masks but yeah that was awesome
that works
made the world a little bit better a
little bit something
um a friend of mine lauren gunderson who
is a playwright started doing
educational
videos about playwriting on uh the
internet and that
gave me you know the idea that there's
something i could do namely educational
videos about physics but of course
there's many many things about physics
on the internet and you've contributed
to some of them so how can you be
different and useful and i thought that
what i could do was just
try to fill the gap between popular
level
discussions
that i've
contributed to also
and textbook level discussions you know
a textbook basically assumes that you're
going to be a professional you're going
to be doing this for years and you're
just doing a little step little bite of
the apple that's going to take you a lot
longer to do and you really need to be
able to solve
problem sets and things like that
whereas the popular level treatments
think that you're afraid of equations
and you can't possibly look at them and
you just need metaphors and analogies
and visualizations
so there is something in between where
you talk a little bit about the real
equations but not at a level where
you're expecting anyone to become a
professional physicist or even solve
problems at homework problems or
anything like that you just want to
understand the ideas so that was the
basis for the videos and it was i didn't
have a lot of time to set it up because
you know we were being locked down i
literally went out and bought a green
screen and a video camera and two days
later i was not allowed to go outside so
it was just in time
and i called them the biggest ideas in
the universe and it's not a great title
honestly it's fine it's it's okay
but it's very unfortunate because i also
have a previous book called the big
picture and that kind of confusing
between those two but so be it you know
it was stuck there and then when i
pitched them as an idea for books uh the
publisher and i agreed that it just
makes sense to use the same title
because some people will know the videos
and therefore they'll be interested in
the books because they're very
complementary although the videos were
much more informal in slapdash and the
books i'm careful and i make far fewer
mistakes in the books than i did in the
videos
and then the big issue was okay how many
books i did 48 videos you know 24 videos
and then 24 q a follow-ups
um
my vision was one giant book i was going
to write a thousand page book and that
would be the magnum opus of you know all
the physics you need to know
so the publisher came back said how
about we break it up into seven books
because short books are very popular
right now and i said no that it would
just like book three would make no sense
right i mean you'd be caught in the
middle of a whole bunch of things
so we compromised on three books and
that there's actually a pretty natural
division book one is all about classical
physics up to and including relativity
book two will be about quantum physics
and quantum field theory book three will
be about emerging phenomena complexity
and the bigger microscopic world
now i couldn't help when i first heard
about what you were doing is reflect
upon our mutual friend lenny suskin past
guest on the podcast and his so-called
theoretical minimum for those uh you
know that might be on the fence about
whether to buy you know three versions
all three versions of this book or just
two
um you know i should point out the audio
version is read by sean and um and the
the text versions are written by sean uh
but uh so you should buy all three but i
i wonder how what is the relationship
between those wonderful books by lenny
and this particular series that you're
envisioning yeah i think there are
basically only two books that are
competitors to this series one is the
series by lenny the theoretical minimum
and then of course uh another previous
podcast guest roger penrose wrote the
road to reality where he really just
goes a lot into the equations and so
forth and i think the differences are
pretty clear i mean penrose is a genius
but he has his quirky idiosyncratic take
on a lot of these issues and it's not
always necessarily the mainstream view
so it's his view and it's great it's
very worth learning but it's a little
bit different than what the average
physicist would give you so i my goal is
to really not in this particular set of
books
be speculative in any way and in that
sense it's very different than my
previous books most of my books
try to present an argument it's not just
here's some pedagogy hear some cool
stuff it's like here is something i
think is true not everyone agrees let me
explain the reasons why plus and minus
whereas in the biggest ideas i'm just
going for the known classics you know
the ideas that are accepted will still
be accepted a thousand years from now as
useful to uh modern physics so in that
way it's different than penrose uh
compared to suskin you know it's a
little bit more
my my books are a little bit more
explicitly meant for this purpose you
know his books came out of more or less
formal classes that he was teaching at
stanford not to physics majors he was
teaching to a more general audience but
they're a little bit more traditional
physics classes you know they go through
the steps in the usual order and you
know they teach you how to diagnose a
matrix and whatever and so it's a little
bit you know it's a it's a broadly aimed
physics course but it's still a standard
physics course whereas what i can do
since i'm not pretending to be a course
so i'm not pretending to sort of march
through the curriculum in any standard
way
the first book has einstein's equation
in it and this short shield metric you
know with all of the details the second
book will do the whole standard model of
particle physics you know i can skip to
the good stuff so i think that's the
fundamental difference between my books
and lennies but you should buy them all
and penrose is also these are all great
books
yeah we'll get to penrose because he was
a guest on the podcast
just last week we're recording this in
august but he was on for the occasion of
his 91st birthday and i know you've had
him on your show as well and the context
of what we spoke about last week was his
you know rather controversial notions
about collapsing wave functions and and
i asked him a question on your behalf
and i want to get to that later but uh
but i want to start where this
particular book starts which as you say
is basically with math with basic uh you
know foundations of calculus
uh and i've had a very refreshing
obviously i know calculus for many years
but the distinction between you know
just from seeing it from your
perspective and you know that my
audience is the uh smartest audience in
the universe uh you you have the title
of second smartest i know the mindscape
audience is the top two yeah um
it's quite quite erudite but but i have
a lot of aspiring students a lot of
aspiring um you know graduate students
non-traditional students people that
want to go back to school i just was
honored to receive an award at my alma
mater at brown university called the
horace mann medal and graduating in
front of me or seeing it was manfred
steiner who uh received his phd in
theoretical physics with brad martin at
age 89. uh he was actually 90 when he
got his actual phd because of covet
what do you say when people say i want
to go back you know and and do this in
my second life if i could do it again
i hear this a lot about people
you know wanting to go back for their
mba or go back for their you know
maybe even their law degree or their
medical degree um sometimes i hear it
about physicists too is it is it as
practical or impractical to do any one
of those august professions as it is to
do physics as a phd and become a
professional physicist well i think i
would actually argue for distinguishing
or or separating the idea of getting a
phd and becoming a professional
physicist these are both two worthy
things but they're different things i
think this is one of the shame
uh shameful aspects of our current
educational system is that we only let
you in to do a phd if we think you want
to become a professor of physics and
then maybe 25 of the students will
become professors of physics right and
you know the rest of them are just
triaged out of the field i think it's
worth learning physics whether or not
you're going to become a professional
physicist and i think that's really what
gives me the opportunity in these books
to do something different because i'm
not even pretending that you want to be
a professional physicist i'm just trying
to teach you the ideas you will not be
able to solve for the procession of
mercury once you've read my book but you
will know what a light cone is and you
will know why there is gravitational
deflection of light and gravitational
redshift you won't be able to compute it
because you're not going to become a
professional physicist but you'll be
able to understand it and i think that
the idea of people understanding and
appreciating and loving physics should
be absolutely universal and free of
whatever restrictions of age and current
state of the world that you're in
becoming a professional physicist is
much much harder because it's like
becoming a professional nba player right
you know there's a lot more people who
want to be professional basketball
players than who can hack it
uh and that's fine it's not like it's a
mistake of society that we don't have
three million professional basketball
players right um this is the feature of
the system that is not going to go away
even if we did we would still all be
watching the best ones
and likewise i don't i don't know what
the right number of professional
physicists is but i do know the right
number of real physics lovers people who
appreciate and want to learn more about
it could be much larger than it is right
now um so i want to push back uh with
love and respect as i always do uh but
on two things one i do think it's for
professional aspiring physicists because
i i've recommended this book or you know
when it comes out to aspiring high
school students i've recommended lenny's
books actually to um you know friend of
the show eric weinstein his son zev
wants to you know has basically rolled
together you know a graduate level uh
course in physics as a high schooler and
and one of the books series i
recommended him was lenny's book series
which i think are quite fabulous and i
think yours even
distills things in even more perhaps um
approachable fashion so i think i think
you can get this book if you're a high
school student and you do want to aspire
to get a glimpse of what you're going to
learn for real maybe in grad school but
at least see it in uh before you even go
to undergraduate i mean it starts with
calculus as and i think you you know it
was probably intentional to do that um
the other thing i want to put sorry
about brian i need to i need to push
back on your pushback because you're not
pushing back at all i 100 agree with all
of that i mean i would have been
incredibly in love with this book when i
was 15 years old right i mean this would
have been just absolute candy to me
because it's the idea at least the hope
the aspiration is to be very very
accessible to people who do eventually
want to become professional physicists
but yeah they don't want to you know
wait i mean a lot of people don't
understand
most people who graduate with bachelor's
degrees in physics probably even most
people who graduate with phds have not
taken a course in general relativity
right
so here is a one you know one volume
book less than 300 pages where you can
learn general relativity yeah you don't
need to slug through all that stuff to
get there and and that's just uh
something i think is very important to
prospective professional physicists but
my point is not only to them that is not
the only target audience yeah i mean i i
think you're being a little overly
charitable with roger i mean i think it
would be very difficult i tried to read
the emperor's new mind as i told roger
and he inspired me as a 15 year old i
didn't understand that even but and it
could have turned me off but it didn't
uh on the other hand i don't i think
lenny's book is is so roger's book is
wonderful but it suffers from this fact
that it's a lot of kind of invented or
novel nomenclature and really thinking
about it as a magician rather than as a
teacher
lenny's book is i think a little bit
higher you know it is for sort of people
in grad school i mean there were people
in his lectures as you know that were
you know ph it was like the feynman
lectures or something that would turn
out to be it would start off with
undergrads and it would end up with
faculty members uh but the other way i
want to push back again with respect is
that you said you know you want to uh
there are there are too many you know
there are we don't need millions like
just like we don't need millions of nba
players we don't need millions of
physicists uh and then i wonder well why
are you doing this um this fellowship
let's let's go there because it's kind
of you know i was joking with with one
of my kids i was it's kind of like i was
telling teaching him the definition of
an attractive nuisance like you're
making this subject seems really
appealing really exciting people are
going to get into it and then you can
offer them a fellowship and really
attract them to it if we have too many
physicists sean like is there a danger
in attracting more by having monetary
rewards so i'm kind of being
tongue-in-cheek but
if you really believe there might be too
many physicists should we just reserve
it for yeah what is the purpose of the
fellowship is it for underprivileged
people is it for people you know from
other backgrounds what's the real focus
of it because in your words you say we
don't need millions of businesses yeah
but i think again number one you're
mixing up learning a field with
eventually become a becoming a
professional in it and number two
whatever the criteria and how many
physicists we need no one thinks that we
need just
rich white people whose parents were
professors to become physicists and i
think that knowing it myself you know
even if you're fascinated with the
subject matter
depending on your background it can be
very unclear how you would even go about
becoming a professional or becoming
educated in this area there's a lot of
pressure to just earn a living you know
make some money be the first generation
in your household which went from lower
middle class to upper middle class right
and some kids out there
are going to be in that position and
they're going to think yeah but what i
really want to do is sort of understand
cosmology or understand metaphysics or
whatever it is and it might be hard for
them you know there's not a lot of money
out there and so the idea of this
scholarship that i've uh started with
bold.org
it's called the mindscape big picture
scholarship and we're raising money to
give up to um well we're giving ten
thousand dollars to someone who's an
undergraduate studying the biggest ideas
right studying philosophy and physics
and mathematics or not not and i should
say or you know one of those things but
there's plenty of people who want to
become doctors and lawyers and that is
great there's nothing wrong with that
but i'm
aiming it at underrepresented groups in
these less practical
areas that i love so much myself and
anyone is willing to either apply if
they're college undergraduates or donate
to the scholarship fund because if we
make enough uh donations we can offer
more than one donation or we can offer
it next year or whatever we're going to
do
yeah and i want to talk about you know
kind of your perspective now that you i
mean your position at caltech you were
advising students and so forth but now
you're you know you're officially a
professor as i understand it in terms of
you know the typical responsibilities
and and and rightfully suits you um
delightfully well um but i want to ask
about you know college seems to me to
becoming more and more of what i call
the academic hunger games i mean first
year like fighting to get people you
know to be uh seen in high school and
get into these places they brag about
rejecting you know at you know one of my
alma maters you know 97 of the people
that apply these are like things that
they brag about and you know to what
extent is it really becoming a luxury a
luxury brand and these colleges uh
should be maybe treated differently and
i know bloomberg has given a lot to
hopkins and there's other
ways that have made it more affordable
but it's still i mean i heard from your
you know one of the places you used to
work at mit they could turn away they
could accept like 10 more classes worth
of students based on quality alone in
other words they're turning away
tremendous numbers of qualified
applicants what's going on here what why
is it that our discipline being a
professor uh physics or whatever um
really hasn't changed in thousand years
at least the last 50 years
after you know a thousand years of
basically having this model where you
have the sage on a stage you know as our
mutual friend david kaiser says you know
one guy is scratching with a rock on
another piece of a rock and and they're
all looking up and wrapped attention um
our profession hasn't changed
substantially at least maybe in 100
years but maybe a thousand years since
the university of bologna opened its
doors in 1080 um i wonder you know how
many other industries can survive like
this i mean it's great we're doing
outreach we're doing you know
demonstrations i do kind of live stuff
on my show
but you know i'm you and i are kind of
rare and you inspired me to do it so
there's not like maybe that many people
that you can inspire to actually do it
that are faculty i believe i should say
that faculty have a moral obligation to
to give back to the public in some way
but let's let's let's not talk about
that
education uh what's wrong maybe you
don't think anything's wrong but but i
feel like it's become a luxury brand
that we kind of are proud of the fact
that we turn away more you know 30 times
more than we could substantially educate
well i think that there's a whole bunch
of things going on here at once and the
first thing i should say is i am not a
professional at
thinking about how to improve the state
of education i'm a professional educator
but there are people who actually study
how you can do it better and there are
people who think very hard about
education policy and how we can make the
flow of money more equitable things like
that and i'm not such a person so i'm
just bloviating right now about how
things should work take it for what it
is worth um and i do think that there
are things changing i mean here we are
on a podcast right which couldn't have
existed a hundred years ago so um there
are videos there are online courses i
always encourage people to take really
good online courses and moocs and so
forth one dream uh makes courses i'm
doing yet another course with them so
there's more opportunities out there but
i think you're you know you're right
pointing at the sort of standard issue
higher education paradigm um there are
flaws in it absolutely you know i used
to be the university of chicago which
famously has always been a really good
school
but when i was a kid you know i was
looking at what universities to go to it
was not a high ranked school in the
traditional rankings and part of that
was because they accepted a huge number
of applicants
percentage-wise and the reason for that
was just that no one would apply to the
university of chicago unless they were
already really really good and you know
wanted to go to the university of
chicago but that is not a way to get up
there in the rankings so they very
explicitly
invoked a new policy to get a whole
bunch of people to apply who so just so
they could reject them
and nothing changed about the university
or student body but they skyrocketed up
the rankings and that's gaming the
system
in uh you know very transparent way and
well why would it work you know why
would people care about that and a lot
of this is is questions for
employers and parents and students you
know why do they care what the ranking
of your school is i mean i remember
running into someone uh who was a young
student who's going to go to law school
and i said where do you want to go to
law school and they said i don't care
just you know one of the top five
schools right and well that that just
rubs me the wrong way it's not what it
should be about
but then there's also issues of you know
the
how we pay for it right and there i
think that things have changed a lot i
mean you know again in my day it seems
that
university educations are a lot more
affordable than they are now and a lot
of it seems and i say seems cause again
i'm not an expert here it seems to me
that universities have learned that they
can make a lot of money by charging an
exorbitant tuition but then just letting
all their students get loans to pay it
back so they're really sort of getting
money from the future of their students
which is great for the university not so
good for the students and so i think
that the student debt burden is enormous
and really really bad yeah if we lower
it uh you know maybe universities will
suffer a little bit and maybe they
should suffer a little bit i
don't want them to suffer but it's a
weird
system and you know throw in also the
fact that public support for public
education has cratered you know states
used to support their own state
universities to a level they just don't
anymore and and i think that california
for example where you are at a state
university is probably better than most
but still not nearly as good as it used
to be right in terms of affordability to
the average student so
and then you have the issue of you know
what is the best pedagogical method is
it just a you know one person at one end
of a log and the other person at the
other end talking to each other uh what
about flipped classrooms and active
learning you know there's just a million
issues that we could talk about none of
which i'm really an expert in i mean
part of me
is just a dinosaur and i think that
there's nothing better than a bunch of
people sitting around a table talking
and one of them is the professor and
some of them are the students but
they're all trying to learn a little bit
and that's what i'll be doing in both of
my classes this fall so i love lecturing
when it's appropriate but you know a
good seminar where we can all talk about
things is really to me the pinnacle of
the university experience yeah it's
right up there with the sabbatical um
but no i i i really i tend to agree with
you and i actually think that you know
in the case of at least private
institutions you know the question of
why are they tax exempt organizations
why do they have to why does you know uh
princeton or stanford brag about you
know having a 50 billion dollar
endowment that grew 30 during or 15
during the global pandemic uh if they're
not going to spend it and then they're
still you know soliciting people like me
for donations uh you know as alumni and
they have this vast network you know so
you take out a loan to go there the
government slash your and you can't
discharge it in bankruptcy uh so these
these you know they operate kind of like
hedge funds i mean that's their their
primary role is to is the sustenance of
the entity here you know i always joke
like how do i distinguish what i do at
ucsd versus ucla uh you know do i know
some special brand of physics you know
do i know the the fourth newton's law
you know is there some other thing i can
add to that to the uh ubra physics no
absolutely harvard doesn't know more
than than uh johns hopkins or san diego
so they tend to now distinguish it based
on perks you know like this dorm you
know on campus near my office as an
ocean view that's pretty nice or there's
a rock climbing wall or there's a gym or
there's a cafeteria with fresh you know
sushi or whatever
so
that seems to me to be getting really
far away from the you know sitting on a
log and and scratching rocks and other
rocks to to map out a picture um yeah i
am i agree there is a beauty to the to
the old way of doing things uh it did
you know some things have just been
successful for thousands of years and
there's a reason for it uh but i do
think things like virtual you know
learning augmented reality i mean you're
a wonderful teacher sean but you know if
i got to sit down with plato and you
know and he was like sitting there in
the room with me
and or with einstein that'd be pretty
good i actually got you know the
collected works of of galileo and for
the first time with carlo rivelli your
friend carlo and others we made an audio
book called the the dialogue on the two
world systems where he and i narrate it
with another italian physicist
uh carlo and fabiola giannatti reads
galileo's introduction and frank
wilcheck reads einstein's introduction
but i started to think sean well now
i've got a million words of galileo it
takes 21 hours to listen to the whole
darn thing um
you know well what if i put it into
gpt-3 uh would you get out a convincing
you know simulacrum of galileo and if
you did could you use that in an
educational framework do you have you
thought about you know where ai could go
where my my handy device behind me could
go uh in the future of education
yeah i mean i think that we're nowhere
close to anything like that uh of course
you could put a whole large corpus of
any one person into gpt 3 or any other
ai program and get something out that
would sound a lot like them because it
is just their words slightly rearranged
right i mean that's not really very
surprising to me but then as soon as you
start asking questions out of context uh
it's easy to see that it has no insight
it has no understanding and i'm not
someone who thinks that it couldn't have
insider understanding but uh the
optimization problem that is being
solved right now is for cheap tricks
is for things that look good and slick
and will amaze you without having that
deeper understanding so someday we'll
have that deeper understanding that'll
be great and then everyone will have
their personal physics tutor and that'll
be wonderful but it's not you know
something that i'm worried about uh in
terms of my own job security
yes
my venal instincts are or to you know
make sure it doesn't horn in on my
racket uh but um i want to turn then uh
also
kind of on the idea of of where this
book ends up which is which is uh with
einsteinian gravity and you do have an
understanding of it um yes you you go
through the math there is you shouldn't
you shouldn't you know under under
promise what you what you do in this
book it it actually shows in a very
detailed appendix i checked all the math
i did all the um it's really fun and
it's great to see the diagrams in this
book i don't know if you drew them or
not i know some of them you drew in real
time on your on your video series on
which this is based um but you end up
with einstein and uh i want to talk just
pertinent to the conversation we just
had about artificial intelligence um do
you know what einstein called his
happiest thought sean do you remember it
was the principle of equivalence that's
right so you want to explain that for
our audience what did he actually say uh
for the audience that was his happiest
thought well you know he's paraphrasing
einstein became famous in 1905 his his
miracle year and one of the things he
did there was special relativity that's
the theory that says you know there's no
such thing as an absolute velocity
except for the speed of light which
everybody agrees on right and that
sounds pretty benign but it's hard to
get into a comprehensive system and it
was almost all in place before einstein
came along what he did was really say
you can get rid of ether all you need to
do is change your notions of space and
time and it wasn't until two years later
that his professor herrmann minkowski
said you know your picture albert uh
works even more beautifully if you think
of it as combining space and time into a
single four-dimensional space-time and i
have a nice you know quote in the book
where einstein in a paper is saying like
yeah this is just sort of useless
mathematical puffery i don't find this
space-time stuff very interesting but he
did have the problem of putting gravity
into his theory right like once you went
from newtonian mechanics to relativity
you had to sort of relativize all of
physics and happily electromagnetism was
already relativistic that's what
inspired relativity but newtonian
gravity wasn't
and he really thought hard about how to
do it because the easy ways didn't work
there's sort of some obvious tricks to
try and they all failed so his happiest
thought was he was thinking about the
nature of gravity
and he realized that if you were in a
box a sealed room
you wouldn't be able to tell in
principle whether that box was just
sitting stationarily on the earth and
you're in a gravitational field or if
you are in a rocket ship and the rocket
ship is accelerating at one g right
and the reason why is because and
everyone says that here's what they
don't say
you can tell whether you're in an
electric field
if you're in a box versus moving in the
electric field because a positively
charged particle and a negatively
charged particle react differently to an
electric field the fact that the
acceleration downward is exactly the
same for everything for every kind of
particle that's what makes it equivalent
to accelerating okay that's what makes
the gravitational field equivalent to
accelerating in a rocket and that is
special when it comes to gravity that's
a feature that is true for gravity but
not for any other force and so what
einstein realized was that therefore
this specialness of gravity
implies that gravity is not a force
living within space-time like the other
forces that we know and love it's a
feature of space-time itself one that
affects all the particles in the
universe in exactly the same way that
was his happiest thought and so then he
has to say okay what does that mean
this is why you or i could have that
thought it's a pretty happy thought but
then there's going to be math involved
right you have to turn it into physics
and again he was smart enough to say you
know okay my old professor minkowski
said space-time uh it's a way of
thinking about the geometry of
space-time maybe if space-time had a
more interesting geometry that could be
gravity but he had no idea what that
meant so he had to talk to his friends
and learn about rybanian geometry and
tensors and all this stuff and he
plugged through it because he was a good
scientist and he invented general
relativity yeah and that's right which
later allowed him to make a blunder
which he would regret for the rest of
his life would turn out to be a blunder
to call it a blunder but the the the
fact that i was trying to get at and i
name drop talked about this with nick
bostrom recently who i know is a friend
of yours a friend of your show um and i
said you know by what you know sense
could you imagine a super intelligent
you know as he calls it s i
um
having a
the uh experience of of a happiest
thought
you know i don't know how my
computational device behind me could
experience joy but also if i just
dropped it out the window you know i
don't know if it would think about it
being so happy but i think part of it
was the visceral
feeling that einstein could could do a
good dunkin experiment about right so he
had a visceral had a corpus of body and
body how can an ai do that and i asked
this of of again i hate to name dr but
you know what else you gonna do i mean i
remember you once said sean one of the
most annoying words that people can hear
another person say is on my podcast but
what the hell sean i mean i'm talking to
you i use it all the time i've talked to
noam chomsky and he said he made a very
convincing case that you know the one of
those you know things that turing really
appreciated is is you know that can
machines think is like you know can can
submarines swim it's it's very different
way of thinking in other words there's
there is an importance to cognition uh
of the words but also of the visceral
experience in other words the fact that
we have a body and we can gesticulate me
more than you because i'm a new york jew
um
but but you know if i lose my hands i
become mute
but but the point being
that aids in not only grammar but
communication but in thought processes
so chomsky says body and embodiment of
neural ideas is kind of the ghost in the
machine uh and then on the other hand
bostrom says no just you know moore's
law continuing forever will get this in
silico where do you come down is there
is there some you know
how
a as a as a you know podcaster that i
look up to when you hear two different
ideas and you think one of them is
totally totally not how do you maintain
because i know that's happened to you in
190 episodes or more of mindscape
but how do you deal with that a and then
we'll get into the actual discussion of
whether or not you believe that a um
that body or something is necessary for
the happiest thought to emerge that
leads to an idea like gr that you finish
this book with so first how do you deal
with with divisive you know thought
processes in real time on a podcast yeah
you know i think that my goal as a
podcaster is not to debate the guest
it's to let the guests give their
perspective and their knowledge in the
clearest and most digestible way
possible i will certainly note my areas
of disagreement along the way and
sometimes i do disagree
just had simon conway morris on the show
who is a wonderful guest but he is what
we call a theistic evolutionist he
thinks that god guides the course of
evolution even though he's an
evolutionary biologist so i disagree
with that and i am happy to say so and
i'm not going to invite someone on the
show who doesn't want me to say so but
because i will but you know then i
always only get guests who i think i can
learn something from just because i
disagree with them about something
doesn't mean i can't learn from them
about something else so
yeah you know i will very often have
people who disagree with other guests of
the show i don't think that's a big
worry
yeah
so uh one other question just from my
own vinal uh self-interest when you're
you've done so many of these wonderful
interviews it's one of the few podcasts
i have in my regular staple diet uh and
you can get that we'll have links to
that we'll have links to sean's um the
the the fellowship that shawn's raising
money for
um but also how do you know
when you're doing a podcast in real time
or can you that you as a host are doing
a good job in other words how do you
know because you don't get feedback
until months or weeks later when you
release the episode and someone says
you know how did you let you know tom
delong say that you know or the gym
semi-van i had on my show and he's like
oh the cia doesn't do this information
it's illegal and then brian you let that
slip you're a shitty podcaster you know
how do you handle that in real time how
do you know that you're doing a good job
or a bad job
well i don't think that counts as
necessarily a bad job i mean it's a fine
line to draw between noting your own
disagreement and arguing with the guests
and yeah there's plenty of people out
there who will argue with the gas
there's plenty of debates there's plenty
of round tables plenty of disagreement
on the internet there's no shortage of
that i think there is more of a shortage
of people respectfully dialoguing and
trying to learn from each other so
that's what i try to do i don't always
do it well i absolutely do some
interviews better than others i mean
sometimes i won't say who but there was
a recent interview where the first half
was great and the second half wasn't um
i've had interviews but the first half
was terrible in the second not terrible
you know not terrible it's never
terrible but i get better at it and part
of it is that different guests like
talking about certain things more than
other things right and you might not
know ahead of time
that's not i don't think it's my fault
if the guest is just much more
comfortable talking about part of their
work than some other part of their work
or something like that
i also think that you know we don't i
don't know about you but i never took a
course on podcasting yeah there is no
one skill called podcasting
yeah there's a million little skills
right so i think that you have to get
better by you know your own gumption of
realizing that you can get better and
putting effort into thinking about how
you can do that you know i know that
early on my audio quality was not as
good for one thing but also i was too
over prepared and a little bit um too
insistent on following a certain kind of
path through the interview and things
like that and i've loosened up uh a
little bit um and you know i do try to
be more
uh
sort of sensitive to what the
what the guest is wants to talk about
and doesn't want to talk about and so
forth but you always make mistakes it's
human beings in conversation that's what
it is also i don't edit my podcast so
whatever happens happens and you know
people are going to hear that
that's like you know swimming naked and
hoping no one else is around which i
will be doing later on tonight no i'm
just kidding um so getting back to the
to the real aspect of that question was
you know can a machine think um so
here's our friend albert and he feels
happy you know there he is smiling and
he's in free fall uh so i just did a
demonstration but for those of you who
are you know i've got to give the
alternate text so those of you that are
listening i just dropped my finger
puppet of albert einstein all of them
have seen those guys be i even have a
finger puppet of noam chomsky if you can
believe it someday they'll be one of you
i'm sure um so uh but i want to ask you
can a computer have a sensation of
happiness a and then b can it visualize
through a human experience or or a sort
of perspective freefall in einstein's
case uh that leads to an insight that is
sort of the culmination at least of this
book but maybe as one of my late great
colleagues hans parties to say the
culmination of western civilization is
gr so where do you come down on this
well i think that it's important here as
in many cases to distinguish between
questions of principle and practice
uh i'm on bostrom's side in the sense
that in principle i don't think there's
any thought that human beings can think
that a machine couldn't think also
but there's a big gap between making
that statement and saying any day now
we're gonna have uh theoretical
physicists replaced by artificial
intelligence okay because i don't think
we're anywhere close to that in the near
term for more or less exactly the
reasons that chomsky was highlighting um
and i've had people on my podcast who
have talked about this but way back from
the early days lisa aziz zadeh was uh
someone who talked about embodied
cognition
where the fact that we have bodies
really matters it matters a lot to how
we think as a matter of fact does it
need to
i don't know i mean maybe there's a
different kind of thought that happens
completely irrespective of bodies but as
a matter of fact the way human beings
think is highly conditioned on the fact
that our brains are part of bodies right
unless you're a dualist unless you're
really a cartesian dualist and think
that the mind is completely separate
from the body these two things are
related and forget i mean you raise
interesting and important things about
sensation and experience but i think of
motivation and values and goals right
you know human beings get hungry and we
get tired and we get cranky in ways that
computers just don't right
and i think that's important i think
that
we we are open systems that are
constantly you know
experiencing from a very different point
of view i had a psychoanalyst on mari
rudy who was talking about the lacanian
theory of lack
and i think that it's actually quite
closely connected to the fact that we
need free energy as physical systems to
survive we're open systems we're
dynamical you know like i can
the example i often give is you can sit
as
stationary as you want and you can be
mindful and you can slow your breathing
but
your heart is still beating your atps
are still being generated in your
mitochondria right there's a lot of
churn going on beneath the surface
because you are a dynamical system and
if you don't
take in
resources from the environment you will
very quickly break down on cosmic times
john's is this your way of telling me
you need a coffee break i just you know
i just give hints i don't i don't say
things explicitly i speak in parables um
but but look you know this is something
where maybe someday we'll have computers
who mimic that and then they'll become
very human-like in their thought process
i see no reason why not but again i
don't think we're anywhere close yeah i
asked that on nick i said well yeah
maybe it would be behoove us to take you
know our computers and like pull a papa
circuit breaker or pull a capacitor
every now and then to tell it what what
pain feels like but he sort of started
he looked at me like i just kicked his
dog or something so
he's a he's a delightful guy that
episode i don't know if that came out
before or after this episode but look
for that and you have a wonderful
interview with him as well sticking with
quantum mechanics and also a relativity
um so as i mentioned i had on
our friend mutual friend sir roger
penrose who's delightful as ever at age
91
and you know that he has this
orchestrated or theory which he didn't
have when i read uh emperor's new mind
uh it came about afterwards because a
man by the name of stuart hameroff who's
an anesthesiologist at uh university
arizona contacted him after that book
and said you better look at these
microtubules so i had on stuart and
roger on to talk about this
and um and we went into some detail
about it but one of the things i kind of
pressed him on and i don't know that
he'd really talked about it is you know
does consciousness exist
in non you know copenhagen
interpretation framework so in other
words would it exist and i know you hate
this phrase but most of my colleagues or
most of the listeners will be more
familiar with the many worlds
interpretation i know you don't use that
but let's just call it that for
simplicity um in the many worlds i asked
him you know would consciousness take
place because there is no collapse so
there's no orchestrated uh you know
objective uh reduction so
in your mind um and he said he doesn't
believe that you're right
uh so he doesn't have to answer that
question um someone asked you in
fairness to you
he wasn't like you know denigrating any
everett or or anything that you've
worked on but he's just saying he
doesn't believe in that so therefore
it's an irrelevant question and then he
you know he's he snorted at me um does
gravity play a role in consciousness or
does gravity play a role in quantum
mechanics let me ask that question
because in his model you have the wild
curvature you have this this collapse
that is instantiated by some
gravitational process that i don't fully
understand happening in the microtubules
which are operating in the squishy wet
warm room temperature environment but is
it okay i'm not going to say is it
conceivable because you always say
that's your least favorite type of
question on your amaze which i listen to
as a supporter on patreon and everyone
should support sean but anyway could
consciousness be affected by gravity
sean
i you know and not in my view
and look just to so the audience is able
to put these things in perspective
there's there's two things going on here
one is um penrose has an idea about the
foundations of quantum mechanics one in
which the schrodinger equation is not
always true because wave functions
explicitly collapse onto random things
under the right circumstances and those
circumstances are governed by
something having to do with gravity and
you're not alone and not knowing exactly
when that is it seems to be a little bit
difficult for people who are not named
roger penrose to pin down when exactly
that collapse happens the other is the
connection to consciousness and you know
i'm not even going to talk about that
because i don't understand it and i
don't care that much i'm a physicalist
about consciousness i think that
whatever consciousness is it could
happen under whatever interpretation of
quantum mechanics you want
but just so everyone knows out there i
mean it's not
even in principle a solution to what
david chalmers would call the hard
problem of consciousness there's
telomeres to be very quick to tell you
you can't just change the laws of
physics and solve the hard problem of
consciousness it's not a matter of the
dynamics of the wave function that's not
what the question is about so you
haven't solved it and it's not really
what penrose wants to solve what he
wants to solve is the calculational
capacity of human cognition which is a
different thing than what we think of as
the hard problem of consciousness
and the other and he has elaborate
arguments involving kurt girdle and
computations which i don't find
convincing either and and experts in the
field don't find convincing but on the
pure quantum mechanics level um his
theory belongs in a category of theories
known as objective collapse theories and
they're treated as fairly respectable
but certainly minority points of view
among people who think about the
foundations of quantum mechanics it gets
a lot more airtime on podcasts and in
the public media because it's roger
penrose yeah but there are a bunch of
people who work very very seriously on
the foundations of quantum mechanics and
they do not think a lot about penrose
and hammeroff's orchestrated objective
reduction theory yeah i agree that's
that's certainly true and i think you
know they yes it's fun to talk to them
it's actually really interesting to talk
to stuart as well uh because he does do
things uh that uh you know
he can be an experimentalist and uh and
actually play around in some sense as he
says with anesthesiology and putting his
patients to sleep and that's what he
gets paid to do i said join the club
that's that's what i do when i'm
teaching come on stewart well and also
it's important to point out that of
course they could be right i'm letting
people know that they have a very very
minority point of view that is not
popular among physicists or philosophers
in the foundations of quantum mechanics
doesn't mean they're not right but i
think there are reasons why their view
is not popular and part of it you sort
of alluded to when you you know say it's
kind of hard to pin down what their
point of view is
uh which is not a hallmark of a
well-constructed scientific theory
and on that topic i talked to stuart i
said one of the questions i had uh was
about the opposite of anesthesia sort of
like
ayahuasca or
psychedelics and actually one of my
audience members is asking uh me if i
would ask you if you'd like to do an
edible right now i'm just kidding but
they're asking have you ever
experimented with mind-enhancing
chemicals besides your treasured
cocktails which i've experienced
any mind enhancers in the in the um
not agitating but sort of enhancing
cognition as these psychedelics are
thought to do
well i think that's not the right way to
think of them i did do lsd once that was
the entirety of my um experience there
it's recounted in my wife jennifer
willett's book me myself and why
searching for the science of self so we
both did it exactly because there are
these claims that uh you have a
different level of cognitive capacity
when you're on psychedelics and i'm a
huge believer that psychedelics have
possible therapeutic uses i think it's
an absolute tragedy that very cheap
arguments about
the drug scare have prevented scientific
research from being done on the
so-called scheduled one drugs in the
united states and england and other
places it's beginning to break down i've
had people on my podcast like robin
carhart harris who do professional
research on psychedelics and it's
enormously um promising for therapeutic
uses i don't think it's promising for
being a smarter person uses it's a
different kind of thing i mean the very
very clumsy but i think
helpful way of thinking about what
psychedelics do is the brain
is really really noisy underneath the uh
surface right there's a lot going on in
the brain and you sort of get attuned to
this when you're asleep and you're
dreaming a little bit and some of these
sort of mismatch of um
visions and sounds comes to your
forebrain but in your everyday life you
sort of suppress a lot of what you might
think of as the vacuum fluctuations in
your brain and what the you know the the
psychedelics don't turn on more activity
they just lower the inhibitions to you
being aware of the activity that is
already there uh so i think that they
have that's that's can be very very
helpful when you're in a rut this is
something that is true for people
struggling with addiction it's true
maybe for people with adhd or something
like that and maybe under the right
circumstances it can make you more
creative it does not help you doing a
derivative or an integral i promise you
that sean i don't know if you're aware
of another podcaster named tim ferriss
not the astronomer timothy faris but tim
ferriss
and he has created an endowment at in
partnership with johns hopkins called
the center for psychedelic and
consciousness research um and that's
part of their medical establishment
there so i don't know if you've
encountered people from there but sounds
pretty interesting sounds like it's
right up your alley and it sounds like
it's for a good cause treating ptsd
using you know controlled i don't
remember from jennifer's book if
the circumstances of your lsd experience
but in this context um it's supervised
medically by arguably the top medical
institution in the world at johns
hopkins so i want to just include that
uh for
for completeness in this discussion i'll
have a link to tim ferriss's blog and
stuff and and maybe you can
help participate in that
very good uh so getting back to quantum
mechanics um
i
think one of the most
mystifying and magical things that comes
out of part of this book
but will rely on the second volume to
get to quantum mechanics is the fact
that you talk about the principle of
least action which you know some have
called like past guests sabine
haasenfelder you know as close to a
theory of everything as we have i'm not
going to debate that but but you know
these things that arise from from things
called poisson brackets and commutation
relations and let's nerd out for a
little bit um i find it very mysterious
that we have these things in classical
mechanics that we can do as
undergraduates
that vanish when you do certain types of
measurements and then you merely add you
know the square root of negative one and
some constant with the proper dimensions
uh and and then in quantum mechanics
they don't commute and in fact they give
you these these imaginary numbers um not
complex but uh
isn't that astounding i mean where where
in other words we we have these
commutation i think born has them on on
his tombstone uh the the commutation
relations that don't vanish so between
position and momentum but in classical
mechanics they do is that something
deeply hidden you know for real this
time
that the same structure the same
mathematical operations when applied
classically versus to a quantal object
are so radically different and then it
involves the square root of negative one
what the hell's going on there
i don't think the square root of
negative one is a big deal here um but
it's helpful as a mathematical trick i
also what i really think is that you
know we human beings have to get over
our preoccupation with classical
mechanics classical mechanics is not how
the world works the question should not
be and i mean the way that you phrase
the question is exactly what every
physicist would do so this is nothing
about your particular formulation but
everyone says like okay classical
mechanics and you have position and
momentum and things are happening and
then quantum mechanics things become
weird okay
well but the world is quantum mechanical
i mean you can say that but you're only
making a statement about your benighted
view of the world you're not making a
statement about nature the statement
about nature should be of the form
here's the quantum world here's how it
works and there's something called the
classical limit where things are
different okay
and from that perspective you know it
just begins to make a lot more sense
because you're not swimming uphill
against these presuppositions of the
classical way of thinking about things
in quantum mechanics position and
momentum are not two things that are
true
they're not features of the system
they're possible measurement outcomes
but they are not characteristics of the
system and you gotta get over that
classical way of thinking about it and
when you do your you know internal view
about quantum mechanics becomes a lot
more peaceful so sean do you have time
for some audience questions and then
some final questions from yours truly
let's do it right okay so audience
questions we already asked the one about
uh psychedelic so we no longer have to
ask that question
um
so one is asking about your largest hope
for the james webb space telescope is
there a certain question or topic that
is within the purview of the jwst that
could be answered by them
you know when i was at caltech i was
contractually obligated to say nice
things about ligo yes because ligo is a
celtic experiment and
i didn't i didn't have any difficulty
doing that because lego is pretty
awesome now at hopkins i'm contractually
obligated to say nice things about jwst
because literally i can look out my
window
in this office i'm in right now at the
space telescope science institute where
jwst is is controlled from and again
it's not a hard obligation to live up to
because i think it's going to do a lot
of wonderful things um what i need to
emphasize is
i don't think there's any
research question that i myself am
working on are deeply interested in the
jwst is going to help us with it all
because i want to know what the
fundamental laws of physics are at an
even deeper level than we already
understand them and jwst is about the
working out of the known laws of physics
in astrophysical situations it's about
galaxy formation and star formation and
supernovae and planets and all that
stuff and i need to really really
emphasize that that is really
interesting and important
even though it does not teach us
anything about quantum gravity it's okay
it doesn't need to teach us anything
about quantum gravity to be interesting
okay so when i say on the one hand it's
not going to teach us anything about the
origin of the universe of the big bang
and on the other hand it's still worth
doing oh yeah for example you know
exoplanets are something which as much
hype as there has been around them there
should be more it's really just amazing
you know when i was in grad school we
didn't have any exoplanets we didn't
know about any planets around other
stars and now we have thousands of them
and some of the
things that we've learned about them
have been a bit surprising
and i'm looking forward to more
surprises and jwst as a giant infrared
telescope is going to be able to sort of
look at starlight shining through the
atmospheres of extrasolar planets and
learn about what those atmospheres are
like and you know in some crude way that
was not what it's optimized for but
it'll be a little bit
come on that's gotta that's just like
you know something my young self would
have would have flipped out over like
let's get excited about that i think
that's really really fun yeah and you
had a podcast uh not too long ago with
uh
i think it was it fisher
um
oh say that yeah john yeah josh
yeah that's right um good uh so actually
i want to take the liberty of asking the
host prerogative so you talked about pan
uh you talked about finding exoplanets
and and of course the hope that there'd
be life on it i i don't think we've ever
talked about alien life i i don't know
it's just something you talk about but
it's it's deraguer nowadays in podcast
world um so the first question i want to
ask you is uh is whether or not
since you are
the master basian uh of all basians that
i know in terms of explicating it maybe
not only believing in bayesian
approaches to probabilistic reasoning
but anyway
the fact is uh in 1997
there was a a press conference on the
white house lawn and bill clinton was
there and you can actually see it in the
movie contact uh with uh past guests on
my show at least andruarian who would
make a great guest for you the wife the
widow of the late great carl sagan and
she co-wrote the book contact in which
the movie is based and in that they take
a scene from this uh so that was 1997
1998 they took a scene from the late 90s
late 1996 when there was a declared
announcement um from a discovery of
meteorite uh relics in antarctica a
possible respiratory microbial
respiratory byproducts or something like
that now that was actually you know
vetted by nasa and had to be to be
broadcast from the white house lawn it
was actually some articles were
published in in science and so forth
peer-reviewed and everything and that
showed that their meteorite activity
that can come from mars and land on the
earth at one thing and then that life
could persist potentially and by the way
that's never been retracted formally and
it's never been like there's been a
ritual that we were wrong it's just
ambiguous it hasn't been confirmed or
refuted that's pretty wrong it's pretty
wrong by the way
that i said i know that it's wrong yeah
the the the
the the fact occurs to me that um given
that there is life on earth and given
that it arose a few hundred million
years after the origin of the earth
we've had four billion years for these
little chunks of rocks which by the way
you can win if you're one of the next
100 subscribers to my mailing list
briankeeding.com i send out meteorites
to people in america all i can afford is
to send out american meteorites uh
through the u.s postal service but
gravity will deliver it uh once you get
it
um given that we haven't found life on
mars or on uh any other evidence of life
on mars is there some amount of um of
bayesian prior reasoning that we can
then
diminish the probability of life being
present throughout the universe in other
words we often hear that as soon as life
came on earth which you know we don't
know how that came about maybe it's
panspermia uh maybe it's not but kind of
the fact that reverse panspermia can
occur we can kick tardigrades off of a
chunk of the grand canyon it can go into
space
how come uh can we use that to reason
that life is actually not that abundant
as many people think and certainly not
advanced technological life or am i you
know is this not an appropriate way to
view the problem
well i don't think we can go quite that
far but the fact that we do not see
abundant very obvious life on mars or
other bodies in the solar system
all else being equal lowers our
probability of life being ubiquitous in
the universe on the other hand if your
theory that you're trying to update is
one percent of earth-sized planets have
life on them then the existence of no
life on mars doesn't change your prior
probability very much at all and one
percent of the planets out there would
still be billions of uh places to have
life out there in the universe so
uh you know i draw a big distinction
between life and anything that you think
of as advanced intelligent life right
that's a very very different question
i think that there are good bayesian
reasons to think that there are not that
many advanced civilizations in our
galaxy that is something that we could
have observed very very easily and we
haven't yeah and every time i say that
the the ufo people come on and say ah
wait until this guy is is shown up in
six months when the new report is
released but this has been going on for
10 years and the new report has never
really shown me up so i'm pretty
confident about that
but that's very different than saying is
there simple unicellular life out there
that could be everywhere that could be
on europa that could be even there could
be even multi-cellular life on europa we
don't know um in the oceans of europa
but we'll have to go look you know the
best bayesian does not get very far we
only have two or three data points so we
need to collect a lot more data and the
exciting thing is we're going to do it
that's kind of awesome we're going to be
updating our priors in a substantial way
yeah yeah and i think if nothing else
that discovery in the late 1996
demonstrates that you know people think
oh it would change humanity forever at
the discovery even of a micro of slime
mold on proxima century b would change
forever we have this commun i say no it
wouldn't be and there's proof that i
would because no one like 99 of the
people that even heard about this in
1996 probably still think it was
accurate or could be true and i don't
think we've had this you know great
kumbaya moment across humanity anyway
you have to respond to that but but the
the the next question comes from a very
good fan of yours and good friend of
this show maya benowitz uh from twitter
you can follow sean on twitter at sean m
carol you can follow me at dr brian
keating on twitter
she asks extracting the universe from
the wave function was a very nice talk
my question is this if in principle
whatever information behind the horizon
can be recovered by holography then why
assume a finite dimensional hilbert
space
so i haven't seen this talk but um
well there's a lot going on there for
the person on the street so i'll try to
unpack it there
the the talk that i gave on extracting
the universe from the wave function is
an illustration of this philosophy that
i already mentioned that we should think
quantum mechanically first about the
universe and we have this thing even
among professional physicists where we
have a classical theory of this or that
field or string or what have you and
then we quantize it right to make a
quantum theory but the real world
doesn't do that the real world just
starts as a quantum theory and then has
a classical limit so that's the program
that is being pursued when i talk about
extracting the universe from the wave
function given a wave function in a way
that it evolves what is the classical
thing that that represents and part of
the
one of the things i'd like to do in that
talk which is completely optional but it
makes my life easier is i argue that the
hilbert space of the universe which is
just the
set of all possible quantum mechanical
wave functions so it's a vector space
which means you can add wave functions
together that's all it really means it's
like x and y except instead of two
dimensions you have 10 to the 10 to 122
dimensions there's a lot of dimensions
in in hilbert's space everyone gets it
but that's still that's still a finite
number 10 to the 10 122 is still not as
big as infinity and from the math
methods point of view that matters a lot
that really sort of does affect how you
go about the analysis
so the existence of black hole entropy
is not a problem for this point of view
it's a feature of this point of view it
is one of the reasons why
we think that the universe only has a
finite dimensional hilbert space because
a black hole stephen hawking said a
black hole is entropy and his
argument for that was actually pretty
phenomenological in the physics sense in
other words he didn't have an underlying
deep theory he was sort of not ludwig
boltzmann he was rudolph clausius for
those of you who are big fans of 19th
century thermodynamic history clausius
is the one who invented the word entropy
but he didn't know what it was you know
he knew what it did and it was boltzmann
who eventually explained what entropy
was later and what hawking did is closer
to clausius like he's explaining what
entropy does without saying what it is
in the black hole
and we still don't know for sure but the
you know the leading idea is that it
represents entanglement between what
happens inside the black hole and what
happens outside quantum mechanical
entanglement and here's here's where i
would argue that the typical physicist
on the street
is
cheating a little bit or not taking
seriously enough what's going on
if you
just take a region of empty space
in quantum field theory right quantum
field theory is our best way of thinking
about the world right now the standard
model particle physics qed et cetera
they're all quantum field theories
there is an entanglement between
empty space
in quantum field theory in a region and
the whole rest of the world everything
outside the region everything inside the
world the region is entangled and
therefore you can calculate the entropy
associated with this region do you know
what the answer is brian
no
it is infinitely big it's one of the
divergences in quantum field theory you
know because there's an infinite number
of modes of a quantum field they can be
infinitely small or whatever
and so
the fact that the entropy of the black
hole is finite
even though there are good arguments
that an entropy of a black hole is the
most entropy we can fit into a region of
space
finite is less than infinite
and that's telling us something really
really profound which is that gravity is
not a quantum field theory
in any straightforward way gravity is
something more subtle than that i mean
maybe it's a
sort of bizarre warped kind of bottom
field theory so everything works out
okay but the facts you get to the
question you know the fact that the
holographic principle suggests
what it suggests is the number of qubits
of information
inside a black hole
is equal roughly speaking to the area of
the event horizon uh measured in planck
units and so you can think in some sense
lenny suskin would say of the
information in a black hole as living
just on or just beyond the event horizon
of a black hole but all i care about is
that it's finite
so that's perfectly compatible with
everything i'm doing it actually fits in
very nicely very good okay two more
questions from the audience and then
four short ones from yours truly and
then i'll let you go uh get that
ayahuasca latte you've been craving all
day um what is joy kolbeck good friend
of the show what's the difference
between d coherence and wave function
collapse
oh there's a big difference um except
that there's a relationship because t
coherence can trick you into thinking
that wave functions have collapsed
decoherence is a process that happens
smoothly and
in a way that is absolutely 100
described by the schrodinger equation
okay so you have two different quantum
mechanical systems we usually call them
the system which might be like an
electron or it might be a cat or
whatever it is and then you have the
environment okay so all the photons in
this room all the stuff you're not
keeping track of is the environment and
decoherence is just when the system and
the environment
interact in such a way as to become
entangled
okay
so there are many interactions between a
system and environment that do not cause
entanglement the usual example i give is
if you have a spin you have a particle
that is a superposition of spin up and
spin down and you drop it
professor einstein in his uh principle
equivalence experiment would tell you
it's going to drop the same speed no
matter whether it's spin up spin down or
some superposition right so there's no
there's an interaction between the earth
and the spin namely it's pulling it
under the force of gravity but there's
no entanglement because it's not
interacting differently with spin up
versus spin down
whereas if you shoot a polarized photon
at that spin it might interact this is
something brian knows a lot better than
i do probably uh it'll interact
differently depending on if the
alignment of the spin versus the
polarization of the photon so that's a
chance for entanglement and that would
count as d coherence so it's all
perfectly smooth it's just the
schrodinger equation no magic there but
if you accept the many worlds
formulation of quantum mechanics then
you would say when decoherence happens
the universe branches into different
worlds where different parts of the wave
function of the system are entangled
with different parts of the environment
and to each person living in the world
it looks like the wave function has
collapsed that's the relationship
between wave function collapse if you
don't believe in many worlds if you're
roger penrose then you think that wave
functions just collapse
like that's a thing okay and that's
something that has nothing to do with
decoherence uh so to a many worlds
person decoherence leads to the
appearance of wave function collapse to
a objective collapse person they're
unrelated
ah
okay last question from my audience this
coming we had many many questions but
sean's a busy guy if you want to get
your question answered guaranteed uh
join his patreon for mindscape i'll put
a link to that i'm a patron um
captain brick which i was going to call
my firstborn son
captain brick as in many worlds some
branches are thicker than others i find
it easier to imagine that there are more
copies of world a versus world b
depending on the thickness are these two
views equivalent or is the thickness of
the branch quote baked into the theory
i'm not a hundred percent sure so
hopefully you are but uh what
there's another question about
conservation of energy and branches
thickness versus branch thickness from a
different listener but
if that one doesn't yeah i i find the
thickness of the branch is a useful way
of thinking about it it's just to those
of you who know a little bit of quantum
mechanics it's the wave function squared
that's the thickness so it's the
amplitude for each branch squared and
that is what gives us the probability of
finding ourselves on that branch once
the branching happens
and the the point is that the total
thickness of the wave function of the
universe remains constant but as time
goes on branching sort of slices the
universe into ever thinner branches and
this visualization helps us understand
things like conservation of energy
because the wave function the universe
overall isn't growing at all but the
number of universes is growing and then
we get into this very sticky philosophy
problem which is do we have to wait
until the branching happens
to call the two different branches
different universes or can we call them
different universes even before the
branching happens and they are identical
to each other
so i i see the appeal
of calling them different universes even
before they're branched but i don't
think you can actually come up with a
definition of universe
in which
two things that are really identical to
each other and doing the same things in
part of the same physical system are two
different universes i don't i mean maybe
i'm wrong about that but i think that
the it's better to just bite the bullet
and say that branching happens and you
know this is a situation where all the
math is perfectly transparent it all
works out fine um there's no real
problem here of what the theory says the
only problems are understanding at an
intuitive level which is which is
admittedly a big leap
indeed so sean i now come to the most
exciting portion of the interview where
i get to ask my own
existential questions that we call the
fantastic four or the quintessential
quattro
[Music]
um but to get access to those answers
from sean to my existential questions
you're going to have to subscribe to our
mailing list so you can find sean's
mailing list and his youtube channel and
support that at preposterous universe uh
and mine briankating.com list so to get
the answers that you're dying to hear
from sean you'll have to subscribe over
there sean thank you so much for being a
part of this episode uh sean i want to
thank you and congratulate you on a
number you know of of different uh items
but especially on your new book
um you know the biggest ideas in the
universe volume one space time matter
motion uh it's a wonderful accessible
book i'm actually using it for one of my
uh middle schoolers at home to learn
about calculus and it's a little
advanced for him to learn about uh
special relative although he did have a
lecture from jim gates
in person when i was back at brown on
super symmetry uh but i want to
congratulate you on this book which he
followed he got some some good pointers
um i want to uh yeah congratulate you on
this wonderful accomplishment and uh and
the great success wish you great success
there on the east coast close to the
halls of power may you be a a physicist
on a hill there and influence the the
country towards uh the betterment of all
mankind thank you sean so much
my pleasure and you know keep on the
spirit flying there in southern
california
with the surfing and the sunshine which
i know is is your big deal so uh we'll
miss that
thanks sean
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
you